what happened to me in the ability to
collect child support sex discrimination
on my first job being the victim of
sexual assault having to get an abortion
almost dying as a result and when I
became an attorney
this was not just my bad luck she's won
over a quarter billion dollars of
lawsuits specific to sexual harassment
yeah well what about you are you a
feminist absolutely not why wait to find
out if you believe in second classes I
don't believe my second class that is I
know you're a true believer it's not a
true believer but you have a true
believer in empowerment of right but
yours equal rights so one of the things
I like to do is I like to sit down with
people that are the best at what they do
today we're sitting with somebody who is
known as a woman's victims rights
attorney she's won over a quarter
billion dollars of lawsuits specific to
sexual harassment she's known for
bullying bullies and every time she
comes on camera men are shivering all
over the place wondering who's gonna be
next so with that being said today
Gloria Allred thank you so much pleasure
meeting you
you've got a wonderful documentary out
by the way that came out you very much
seeing all read which is now airing on
Netflix I'm just very thankful to the
wonderful job done by the producers and
support by Netflix it's a powerful story
they wanted to do a story of you know my
battle for women's rights which I've
been battling for 42 years with the
leading women's rights law firm in the
United States you know what I really
wanted to do was to help to empower
women and minorities individuals who are
lesbian or gay or transgender as well to
stand up against injustice to know that
they don't have to suffer in silence
that they can that they have legal
rights they can assert those rights and
that we can protect those rights and we
can vindicate those rights sometimes in
a confidential settlement sometimes in a
court of law sometimes by just
supporting them if they wish to speak
out publicly and have their voice
depending on what is they want to say
and what their goals are and the point
is Patrick that you know women and
minorities for
most part are not going to suffer in
silence anymore they are going to stand
up they are going to make those who have
wronged them who have inflicted in
justices on them accountable in some way
because I always say Patrick that the
cost of the wrong should not be borne by
the victim
it should be borne by the wrongdoer and
we're here to make sure that the
wrongdoers face consequences and they
have to pay the cost of the wrong not
the victim you know I've heard you say
that so many times and one of the things
when I watch your glory and the end of
part that I have respect for you
politically we may be in complete
different sides politically ourselves I
live in Texas are you still in
California 25 years there are things I
think there are things I agree with the
door things I don't agree with equal
rights for women under the law this is
the part I do want to make the point
with you you know you have a love-hate
relationship man you know some men are
oh my god she just wants to go out and
get the media and she just wants to get
the media attention and that's all she
wants to do yeah and I know there are
some men who would like women to be
sorry I want to say something about that
and then there's the other side that
woman are glad that you are defending
them and I want you to know for me I
have a mother have a sister an older
sister and I have a daughter now hmm I
have a two-year-old daughter now so for
me to know if anybody was representing
my daughter it's gonna be you if I'm
gonna call anybody represent my daughter
it's gonna be you but going back to it I
felt there was a but coming
this is the part I think you're a true
believer I am and I think you're a true
believer for reasons that we talk about
on this channel a lot is because of
life-changing events that happen to you
and then Gloria becomes Gloria single
parent you know supporting a little girl
teaching full-time at Benjamin Franklin
High School commuting two nights a week
from Philadelphia to New York to earn my
master's degree at New York University
and also teaching two nights a week at
the cerebral palsy foundation you know
the other two nights commuting by train
to New York it was you know quite a
challenge in those days but when you're
in your 20s and you know you have a
responsibility you have to do what you
need to do and to make it in this world
and this world is not easy but you know
I just assumed responsibility for my
daughter and I'm glad that I did more
power to you for doing that but the part
I want he was gonna die and leave me any
money well you're good you know teach
full-time boys yeah high school Watts
yeah it was all african-american high
school and but the kids were wonderful
and even though they were poor you know
poor kids also want to have an education
they want to do better in this world and
so they have a right to well qualified
teachers what caused you to have these
beliefs like if you go back to growing
up with your parents I know your dad was
a salesperson your mom was a
stay-at-home mom in huh that was a
hard-working man going door to door your
whole door-to-door salesmen hard life
what did you form your political beliefs
well when you say my political beliefs
you mean my belief that women should be
treated with respect and dignity and and
be afforded equal rights under the law
that your daughter your two-year-old
daughter should not be discriminated
against on account of her gender in
education in assignment in business or
anywhere else and that she should be for
- afforded equal rights under the law is
that what you mean that she shouldn't be
the victim of injustice
I don't think actual violence I don't
think most people disagree with that I
think most people when I form those you
know I guess it goes back to my life
experience and when I understand that
what happened to me as a woman in
ability to collect court-ordered child
support on time or in the amount that
was ordered sex discrimination on my
first job Kimbrel brother's department
store being paid less because I was a
woman than a man was paid for the same a
similar job being the victim of sexual
assault having to get an abortion when
it was illegal for doctors to provide
them even though it's not illegal for me
to get one almost dying as a result of
you know an unqualified man who did the
abortion and then wasn't responsible
afterwards and almost having bled to
death well it's my own experience and
when I became an attorney I began to
become aware this was not just my bad
luck okay there are systems and laws
which caused me harm
bortion was illegal because there were
certain men in congress that decided
they were going to impose their own
religious agendas and force women to
have illegal abortions and many were
maimed and almost died and some did die
because that's what they did because
there were laws that were inadequate to
force fathers to pay child support to
force women onto welfare because they
weren't enforcing the laws for fathers
to pay for the support of their children
so the taxpayers had to do it you know I
became aware of the rampant nature of
sexual harassment on the job and sex
discrimination which causes women to be
in a no-win situation and earn less than
men when they're trying to support their
families as well so on and on I saw it
was pervasive it was severe it was
harmful to women and I decided you know
what there's something we can do about
it and we are going to do something
about it we have so that's what happened
so that's what happened let me ask you
so the event in 1966 if that doesn't
take place would you be an attorney
today where we are today for all of us
is the product of every choice we've
made in our lives and some that have
been made for us so all I can say is I
feel blessed to be able to be an
attorney and to help to fight injustice
against women and minorities sometimes
if bad things happen you know you wonder
okay well why me and the answer comes
back well why not you because so many
people suffer in justices and really
I've come to think that maybe there's a
purpose that we don't know at the time
for suffering but rather than just kind
of be get get involved in depression
which is rage turned inward
I believe taking that rage and using it
as a source of energy turning it outward
to win change for others so that others
don't need to be victimized and suffer
in that way so I say to women minorities
don't just turn it inward in fact I
would discourage you from
thinking of you know drugging yourself
to relieve the depression as a way of
tranquilizing yourself out of your anger
and just feel the pain and take it move
it outward and become transformed and
that's I talked about that in the film
seeing already that you can go from
being a victim transformed into a
survivor transformed into the highest
level which is a fighter for change
that's what I encourage because anger
can be a very useful emotion if it's
channeled in a positive way it then
becomes empowering and contagious
empowering to the person who knows wait
it's like I can do something to make
change here to win change and it's
contagious because family sees that
person often as a role model and then
they become change makers in their own
community in the world well you've
definitely sparked a lot of people
that's for sure I mean you are a
champion for a woman across the country
when your name comes up people are glad
you're there to be a voice and you've
set the great example obviously with
your daughters well Lisa Cantona she's
doing a similar thing as well my
granddaughter your granddaughter is
amazing I see that taking place with you
yeah I sent her to law school yeah
that's very fair to be a lawyer Gloria
what is the ward feminism to you well
the dictionary definition is really very
simple it's a person who believes in
equal rights for women with men legally
socially politically and economically so
for I say well then you're either a
feminist or you're a bigot because you
either believe in equal rights for women
with men or you believe that women
should be subordinated as second-class
citizens and not enjoy equal rights
under the law for women with men so
which are you Patrick so I think the
question would be the word liberal was
different 50 years ago than the world
liberal is today yeah but what about you
are you a feminist absolutely not
because I'll explain to you what a
feminism is what your daughter's name
but the way you cornered me and you said
bigoted I could also corner you as well
because I think and I'll give you my
point of view my perspective
you believe in second classes I don't
believe in second class citizen our
company we have six thousand seven
hundred agents I'll give you steady okay
well you can say you know I like women
we employ women but that's really none
in four percent women bill but that
doesn't matter okay my question to you
is do you believe in equal rights for
women with men and you still have not
answered that equal right for what as
equal rights for women with men under
the law Equal Employment Opportunity
short equal opportunity in education
equal opportunity like that it is not
black and white is really black I don't
think it is no for me it's like you're
either white or you're not pregnant I do
what it really is no in-between and
that's the way it is with feminism and
equal rights so if you want to have that
debate can we have the debate
women work 2,000 hours a year on average
man do 2500 statistically you can't
compete that's not the that's not the
issue
my question is I'll repeat it under the
law should women enjoy equal rights with
men
absolutely okay so then what about
economically sure what about socially
sure what about politically sure and
you're ready answered legally why they
don't want to say you're not all right
no we don't have that we have that all
no but let's go back how do you I don't
want to be called a feminist when you
buy your answers to my questions have
just filled the definition but no that's
feminism a person who believes in equal
right no because out today is looking
away from you it's not far from it from
the moment I walked into your office I
saw seven women working here I didn't
see one guy oh well my god my partners
partners are men but I know your two
partners are men like I understand that
no it's not just for partners I'm more
than two partners have you represented
men before of course I have many times
and we have clients who were men now how
many sexual harassment cases move men
well actually we've had a number of
sexual harassment cases I'll tell you
about two or majority men or women I'll
tell you about majority men or one our
majority of what your sexual harassment
cases
okay I'll answer that but I guess you
didn't want to hear about the cases
where we represented men who were
sexually harassed because you then
skipped over and went to a different
question
which question would you like me to
address either one of them okay okay so
I'll go to your first one and then if
you'd like to restate your second one
I'll be happy to answer that one as well
because both are fair questions okay so
yes we represent men two of our very
famous cases and we have more but I'll
talk about two right now one had to do
with a man who was sexually harassed by
another man on the job and it was very
severe as sexual harassment this is
before the Supreme Court of the United
States decided many years ago sexual
harassment law does cover men as victims
as well as women as victims but we took
the risk even before the Supreme Court
made that clear and we represented a man
and we sued another man for sexual
harassment on the job
we won more than a five million dollar
verdict for our client a man who was
sexually harassed by another man we had
another case where a man our client was
sexually harassed he alleged by a woman
this was at Vaughan's grocery store a
well-known chain in Southern California
he alleged that he was sexually harassed
by her and that he was retaliated
against when he protested the sexual
harassment
the jury found after we tried the case
that no he was not sexually harassed by
the woman supervisor but that he was
retaliated against because he protested
what he believed was sexual harassment
he had a reasonable belief that he was
right and we want 16 million dollars for
our client the male victim of
retaliation those are just two of the
cases now I think your second question
is well do you do as many sexual
harassment cases where men are victims
as you do where women are victims is
that a fair statement of your question
okay without the tone having said that
the answer is of course not because most
victims of sexual harassment are women
and most of those who sexually harass
them are men now why is that because
that's the way it is in the workplace
overall where women are June
at the bottom or the middle and men are
in power our life choice of education
well this is the way it is when you say
by choice and education is also this is
these education there is not just
education please let's not demean women
to think that they're not as educated as
bit far mama that's not what I said no I
said by the direction they take on their
education their career route okay well
most career route they take is towards
that and I'll just draw it towards what
towards education wanting to become
teachers wanted to become nurses well
therefore what I don't understand
therefore what there's not a major
opportunity there to move up as it does
on a different rod you go okay well I
mean I totally disagree with that yeah I
mean yes women have been socialized into
job ghettos if that's what you're saying
that's what you're saying I said yes
most teachers are women most nurses are
women you know and this kind of thing
and we are now opening up the job
ghettos so that men can also be nurses
and that's good because that will help
we don't men are considered to be a more
value in our country so therefore the
pay of female nurses should go up
because now it's been our doing it'll be
considered more important work as well
it's not because of that you know there
have been men who I mean women have been
discriminated against they have not been
hired for the top they can see through
the glass ceiling but sometimes they
can't get right breakthrough so it's a
complicated kind of situation but let's
not suggest somehow because of some
factor other than there is
discrimination and women and now we'll
for example what we're trying to do is
educate women and encourage them into
science and math fields where in the
school that's the stem program where you
know many girls have not been you know
encouraged to study science and math
therefore there are more men in the
scientific area than women so here's
water should be encouraged you know if
she wants to be a teacher that's great
we need teachers and we need good
teachers right but if she wants to let's
say become a scientist
stored mathematician no probably God
bless sir let's provide her with that
opportunity and but I'm saying and
there's also been discrimination of
those areas iíve done discrimination
cases you think in every area of life
with sports business education the
religious world the entertainment world
you name it Gloria please know I know
you're a true believer no but it's not a
true believing water sighs I'm a true
believer in empowerment a run of an army
but here's equal rights for them here's
my challenge let me explain something to
you okay so I run a sales organization
okay so running a sales organization
here's what I have to watch I used to
work with a lady who was my boss okay
and she ran the business with her
husband she was the Alpha he was not and
we all responded to her you're an alpha
absolutely all day long times 10 at the
highest level sitting here anyway you're
very brave I want to congratulate you
here's my point you I'm an alpha you're
an alpha the point I'm trying to make to
you is the following
I think feminism this is what it does I
think this will feminism and this my
challenge with it this is why I don't
consider myself a feminist this is where
it goes I think what we're trying to do
is this is the part that gets confusing
we're trying to make men and women equal
no problem under the law under the law
no problem
however for me to say 20 men who are not
alpha can come and deal with you it's
mathematically impossible I don't know
what you mean deal with me I you people
deal with me all the time well you're
not easy to deal with well I do very
difficult that we have a wonder I don't
know about that but I will say this we
have a wonderful saying in the women's
movement that a man of quality is not
threatened by a woman of equality
absolutely not well you know if they
can't deal with me that is there
probably won't mine I'm with you my
number-one earner is a woman who kills
it I'm all about it so what a jerk what
is your question
a reference to being out why are you
pushing about feminism if I'm a feminist
or not I ask you so if you're not a
feminism are you a male chauvinist
no you're just obviously not comfortable
with either label
no no I'm not comfortable we don't have
to label each other but you know the
point is
you know women and minorities should be
treated with respect and dignity and
imported their rights okay that respect
and dignity you know it's a it a lack of
rights is very dangerous
to a woman's economic health her
physical health or social health all of
that financial this is what our America
I lived in Iran for 10 years where Iran
okay well alright so this is because
they don't offer what the freedom is
offered here in America well you know
what I do mother that's a mess it's not
just that we're offered the freedom we
have a right to that freedom horse
under the Constitution under the laws of
our land we still have a long way to go
on that many ways we're like what you're
saying right now is what's your some
when you said I think the stem system
what we're trying to encourage you know
the ladies to get into math and all that
I think that's all good yeah oh yeah I
don't by the way use the word ladies I
it's okay if you want to use it just
because you know people say well why
don't you like the word lady don't why
don't you want to be called a lady well
because you're not my lord and I'm not
your lady as a lady then they think
should I have teacher especially and
they don't want a lady as president of
the United States but a woman is okay so
don't be afraid of the W word which is
woman and also we don't even have to
refer to a gender at all like we don't
have to refer to people's races because
we're just all human being now for me
Ron I mean if I started to decide to use
gender I'd be in a whole different place
the last person doesn't need to worry
about gender and race yeah that's myself
but see now you're not afraid to deal
with me so men should be secure and look
at you and say look we shouldn't be
afraid either you know what because if
they have nothing to if they've done
nothing wrong to women they do not have
to fear me of course if they have hurt
women yes maybe they do have something
to fear Gloria my issue isn't with you I
think you're a true feminist towards
your belief system is I think there's a
lot of propaganda out there that's
pinning men versus women and that's a
whole different story well and there's a
propaganda that's you know well and
sometimes right there against African
Americans I'm comfortable with all the
propaganda as a pinning men against
women and you know am i comfortable with
the truth yes truth matters there's a
value to truth truth is fine
it's
not only fine it's necessary and we're
losing the ability to know what truth is
anymore because we have people in the
White House like the president's
attorneys saying that somehow truth is
relative which it's not but that's on
both sides if you if you through your
saying the Democrats don't lie no III
didn't know what both sides meant I mean
politics left I'm saying it's not
between Democrats and Republicans
between the truth and a lie so let me
ask you what is the difference between
Florida and between it being considered
harassment right I mean if I watch an
episode with you and Morton Downey jr.
it is beautiful because you can tell
there was some kind of an attraction
there you guys are pushing each other
but it was flirting so what is flirting
what is harassment what's the difference
okay well when we talk about sexual
harassment Patrick we're talking about
the job we're talking about unwelcome
words of a sexual nature and or advances
of a sexual nature towards someone who
is less powerful and the key word is
unwelcome it's unwelcome it and it's
severe or pervasive that's sexual
harassment so I'll give you an example a
boss who kisses a secretary on the cheek
once that's not sexual harassment
because it's not severe it's not
pervasive okay so that's not sexual
harassment now if he brings her into the
office and says take your shirt off I
want to see your breasts okay and then
he exposes his penis to her has her
watch pornography obviously that's
sexual harassment if that's not welcome
to her
that's called stupidity now we talk
about consent when we talk about rape we
don't use the word consent in the
employment sector we used welcome or
unwelcome because let's face it they're
not on an equal playing field she is
less powerful she's down here
he's up here she's an economic captive
in many ways she needs to keep her job
she wants to be promoted she doesn't
want to be demoted just gonna lose it so
laws against sexual harassment exist
because the policy of our nation as
demonstrated in the law is that we all
have a right to enjoy Equal Employment
Opportunity sexual harassment interferes
with that right to enjoy equal
employment opportunity it is a form of
sex discrimination so no it does
interfere with women's right to be
employed that's why it's against the law
and well it should be that's different
if two people who are not employed go
out to a bar and meet each other okay
that's not sexual harassment if they're
sitting at the bar and the guy leans
over and kisses her alright
it might be a sexual battery that
nobody's going to prosecute but it's not
technically sexual harassment so it's
good that you ask that question I'm
curious I think education is very
critical in business let me tell you a
lot of people want to minimize sexual
harassment but what I hear from women
who are contacting me every day we're
talking about severe sexual harassment
we're talking about going you know
making a woman come to your hotel room
on a business trip and then you know
throwing her down on the bed and you
know while maybe she's had a lot to
drink or maybe hear you maybe he's
drugged her drink and then he you know
sexually assaults her this is severe
okay and this is wrong it's against the
law so you know the hypocritical side of
it is the following okay again you're a
true believer 100% I've I've read all
your stuff on what and I know you don't
like when I say to true believer you're
a true believer I confess to being a
true believer in equality that's it
that's beautiful so you're in Hollywood
right now okay this is actually how this
is Beverly Hills but here it's not
Beverly Hills either it's Los Angeles
this is Los Angeles okay so we're in LA
right now okay we are less than 30 miles
away from Hollywood
ever take 17 points the Hollywood I can
see the Hollywood sign I'm sorry the
biggest proponents of feminism are in
Hollywood biggest well they've stayed
they scream it off the top of their
lungs I don't know that they're
screaming but they are asserting proudly
that they stand for equal rights with
you while you talk about men screaming
or just women screaming well when they
express their view feminists are both
men screaming as well just saying
generally screaming is a word that's
applied timing and not men I don't know
if you know or not but ice cream as well
ice cream a lot okay well I'm sure
anyway moving on I just want you an ice
cream to our time well I am it's my
scream and I wouldn't describe you as a
screamer
I would describe you as a strong
advocate for your point of view which I
admire people who can struggle you
handle that gentleman that came up on
the Lincoln Memorial and I saw you
handle it and what you said pure respect
for you and I'm a hundred percent there
aligned with what you said so believe me
we are more aligned in many areas than
you think well that's good this is the
part so why did Hollywood hide no one
Weinstein all along everybody so many
people knew why did they hide it
Hollywood is made up of many many
different people I don't pretend to
speak for all the people who work in the
entertainment industry why they hit it
well you say okay we're talking about
many individuals mainly women who were
placed in a no-win situation again back
to the sexual harassment and employment
scenario which I described these many
individuals understood that he had power
to provide them with an employment
opportunity as an actor and that he
could deny that opportunity if they
didn't go along with his sexual
harassment they allege that they were
afraid to say anything they thought
nobody would believe them that they
might end up getting sued but they might
never work again
so yes fear is a weapon that often keeps
the victims from
speaking out and there are real risks
involved in speaking out against
powerful figures so high but I noticed
you asked and that was a fair question
why didn't they speak out sooner
another really fair and important
question is why did he do what he was
alleged to do preying on some predictive
if in fact he did it and the answer to
what you just said which was he belongs
in prison is my god he's going to be a
race right yes I don't know if that's
true but that's what's alleged fair
enough okay
it's interesting to see that taking
place here the fact that fear male like
that I think one of the best things
that's happening right now is there's
examples being made that people are
actually afraid like people are all
actually talking about this this like
you shouldn't right are you talking I am
talking everybody in the marketplace is
playing to the point where they are more
cautious about things they did today
talking about men who are afraid about
the fact that they have hurt women in
the past they may have to be accountable
for it now okay and I agree with you
that there are many men who are in fear
and rightfully so because now they know
that women are a force to be reckoned
with
they cannot just victimize women and
then walk off and forget about the fact
that they have hurt them and not be
accountable they are now being made
accountable it's called the reckoning so
I'm not going to say don't be afraid but
be accountable for what you have done
and then you can move on with your life
if you were running a company and you
are running a company but if you're on a
good company or an entrepreneur how
would you address this with your
employees I am an entrepreneur because
I'm a partner in this law firm Allred
Maroko meaning but here's a difference
floor you're not sitting you're talking
to these guys about sexual harassment
cuz it's what you do 24/7 I'm talking
somebody that's running a business that
they're not in the sexual harassment
business they're not a lawyer like you
how would you handle it yourself I would
educate all my employees train them
about what sexual harassment is and that
doesn't mean just putting up a sign in
the lawn
the gathers cobwebs that nobody reads
because it's like wallpaper they just
walked by it nobody bothers reading it
and it doesn't mean just saying look at
this on the internet it means real
training it means more importantly after
the training making sure that you're
monitoring your workplace to make sure
that there is no sexual harassment in
the workplace and it also means
establishing a system a protocol within
the business where employees can feel
safe in reporting the sexual harassment
and finally that they will understand
that they will not be retaliated against
if they report the sexual harassment and
that there will be significant action
discipline imposed upon the harasser if
after an investigation he or she has
found to have in fact sexually harassing
the victim
so yes it's all of the above that needs
to be done sometimes businesses are
failing in that now they're paying the
cost of that okay because we sue big
businesses and small businesses and you
know and we do a lot of settlement at
confidential settlements with them as
well because their system is broken so
if they're concerned about their bottom
line as every business should be and is
if they want to avoid the cost of
lawsuits and their executives having to
sit in depositions and answering
questions under oath and perhaps being
embarrassed publicly it will be less
expensive to their bottom line if they
would do what I just suggested and make
sure there is no sexual harassment abuse
of power in the workplace that's better
for their workforce it's better for
their bottom line it's a win-win all
around
you know I think Gloria Steinem has once
said something to the effect of we are
forever grateful to the men who support
us I think men and women should be
judged as individuals not like Oh old
men or this and all women or that that's
ridiculous it's a stereotype it never
fits okay so I take them individually
there are some men who
really care about other women and you
know they care about how their mothers
are treated and their sisters and their
daughters and their aunts and they'll
stand up for them and they want them to
be treated better than they have been
and then there are other men who just
you know they just only care about
themselves and they want to hurt women
and they feel very insecure about women
enjoying equal rights
so those men need to be educated so you
know if I sue men who have hurt women
it's a teaching moment for them it would
be better if they could be educated in
other ways and all I can say is that you
know we we need to move forward and we
we need to move forward together do you
feel we are I think we are moving
forward I think this is the age of
empowerment of women we've seen that
through the Weinstein scandal and others
right we've seen that through the
women's marches where women are saying
as to President Trump for example that
we will not allow ourselves to be you
know sexually assaulted we will not
allow men just to grab us and do
whatever they want with us whenever they
want however they want whoever they are
we we are seeing women and and and their
millions of people all over the world
who marched on that women's march for
many reasons but for they brought their
children in their little toddlers and
strollers some of the fathers came older
women young women I saw a woman like she
looked like she was 70 years old with a
sign that says I've been holding the
same sign for 50 years and my arms are
getting tired
okay so the sign is essentially you know
respect women sure so I do think that
women and men now understand what's at
stake and we are moving forward you know
when I was living in Germany at a
refugee camp with my mother and my
sister I was in eleven you knew abort
and they were taking good care of you
right who was your mother and your
sister you were taking care of them too
of course of course and my parents got a
divorce at that time and I remember we
went
a priest's place okay
this guy's place he was gonna give food
or something like that and I all of a
sudden started saying he's bringing a
little bit too much drinks and alcohol
to my family I'm like and I lost it I
was 11 years old never my mom brings it
up till today I said we're leaving this
place so when you say that the
protective nature of me automatically
comes out to know that that does happen
at times abuse happens a lot and it's
great to see that these women have the
courage to come up because there's an
Iran there used to be a thing if you
were married and you got a divorce
you were like done you know you were
done in Iran Gloria let me ask you for
somebody like yourself who you said when
I was a kid I was always known as being
persistent
right you were persistent horses I think
that's the word being persistent and
your friend said you know when when
Gloria we went to school together the
boys loved her she was very popular with
the boys and she would you know your
pictures of you when you were in high
school and all this stuff and your
friend you said you've had four friends
in your life to your partners one is
your daughter Lisa and one is the friend
that was back but anyway yeah but these
are your words you said four that are
very very close friends to me but I
don't have time for more friends you
have had to be so strong on camera in
front of everybody I think you cried one
time when the whole equal marriage when
that came out it was the first time you
cried on a press conference you don't
typically cry on press conference
everybody's sitting around I believe
first we cry then we fight I have heard
you say that yes but the question I have
for you is who is Gloria when you're by
yourself I mean like the same person who
is Gloria go to you know is it you to
you is it is it glory of going to Gloria
like how do you keep yourself as strong
as you have over these years it's a long
time to stay as strong as you can stay
because the alternative is giving in to
injustice and that's not an acceptable
alternative as far as I'm concerned you
know I say in my book fight back and win
you know that my job is to give a voice
to the voiceless and power to the
powerless and hope to the hopeless so
for me to like give in this is not an
acceptable alternative I don't I think
it's my duty to help others because I'm
privileged to have become an attorney to
rise from
row house in Philadelphia with parents
who had an eighth-grade education right
my father only earn enough money to have
enough food for that day and then next
day would be another day where the money
would be put out just enough for the
food for that day and now to become an
attorney I have a duty as a human being
to help others I know the extent and
scope against the of injustice against
people who are the have-nots who would
like to have who would like to be
treated in a way that they can rise and
succeed I am the same person off camera
as I am on camera how do you refuel I
get up every day and I understand what's
happening to victims because I hear from
them and I say what what do you have to
do something about lettuce conference I
have a passion for justice this is that
I enjoy what I'm doing but that's what
I'm getting to if I don't enjoy it on
any day that's okay because I have a
duty my duty is not just to do what I
enjoy if I feel like it I have a time
limit finite time when I'm on the earth
as we all do and I take seriously every
moment is an investment of me and I want
to empower people as long as I am here
on God's green earth which is a
privilege and a blessing and this is
what I'm going to do this is what I
meant to do the rest of my life very
obvious all right so I need to go away
from it that would be horrible to take a
vacation for me would be a punishment
we're on the same page I need to do this
yeah I asked this question because
because some people don't find a purpose
like you have found your so when you
find it it also becomes a passion by the
way you know what each one of us in our
own lives can make that contribution to
others in different ways we don't all
have to do anyway are you of course you
do it or I'm finding that it's finding
that it's looking to find out you'll
know when you do but
here's the point you should find a way
to help others to make that contribution
all of us can do it no matter our
station in life our race our religion
our ethnic origin or our gender we can
all do it we can do random acts of
kindness we can do what Mother Jones
said don't agonize organize we can run
for office we can you know all of us can
help to win change but no one's going to
give it to us no one gives us our rights
we have always had to fight for them and
we will have to continue to fight for
why don't you run for office that's not
what I want to do I am like a private
attorney general Patrick I guess you
wanted a private attorney general this
year what's this you debating well who
needs to enforce the laws that for the
protection of those for whom it was
passed maybe maybe there's there's a lot
of great lawyers I know interested in
running for office I've had people to
encourage me and I thank you I consider
that a compliment but that's not who I
am this is what I want to do the rest of
my life
if I can do it from the great beyond
I'll try it I'll find a way to do it
from there as well one topic we didn't
cover OJ so let me ask you when okay
happened your belief till today in your
mind do you believe it happened do you
believe he did it
where are you at are you reframing your
question do I believe that OJ Simpson is
guilty killed Nicole Brown Simpson and
Ronald Goldman may they rest in peace
and my answer is a civil jury found that
he was liable for the wrongful death
that is a verdict that was affirmed on
appeal and yes I believe that the civil
jury was correct in finding him to be
liable for their wrongful deaths so Jay
killed them according to the civil jury
that's correct so I thank you so much I
appreciate you appreciate you definitely
this was a lot of fun thank you so much
Gloria and that was a lot of fun this
was another thing with an alpha yeah
thank you all right
you